there is a really simple rule that
influences the design of every jet plane
you've ever flown on in profound ways
and once you know about it you'll start
seeing its effect everywhere it tells us
why engines are placed slightly in front
of wings and why the fuselage of
supersonic planes narrows along the
wings and while redesigning the hump of
the 747 to be longer not only allowed it
to carry more passengers but also
increased its cruise speed and decreased
drag this simple rule is called the area
rule and it tells us the ideal
distribution of cross sectional area
along the length of a transonic or
supersonic plane will look something
like this
that includes the wings engines
everything because a gradual change in
cross-section results in a reduction in
wave drag which is to drive data rises
from shockwaves forming over the plane
as it approaches the speed of sound
in reality planes never achieved this
ideal distribution the Conchords
distribution looked similar to this and
could have been closer to the ideal had
they tapered the fuselage over the wing
but more on that later the rule was
discovered as planes started to edge
ever closer to the speed of sound and
designers started to notice that
adjusting the position and shape of
features on the plane had significant
effects on performance take this patent
from the younger company in 1944 showing
obvious attempts to experiment with the
distribution of cross-sectional area
along the length of the plane with the
cross-sectional areas highlighted here
this ultimately led to the
bizarre-looking ju 287
the effect was discovered again by
Richard Whitcomb when testing models in
a wind tunnel in the 1950s his discovery
was used to redesign the f-102 Delta
Dagger which was originally designed
with a straight fuselage the redesign
tapered the fuselage over the wings and
allowed the distribution of
cross-sectional area to more closely
resemble the ideal this small change
along with slightly more powerful
engines brought its max speed from 0.98
Mach to 1.2 - sometimes it's not
possible or does not make economic sense
as was the case for the concorde to
narrow the fuselage over the wing
instead it makes more sense to make the
fuselage before the wing larger to make
the change in cross-section less
dramatic
the 747 800 featured a longer hump for
exactly this reason which allowed its
crew speed passenger capacity
and fuel economy to rise this rule even
affects the placement of engines most
large planes mount the engines slightly
forward of the wing and not directly
under as that would compound the wings
addition to the cross-sectional area and
in narrow-body planes the engines are
often mounted above and behind the wing
for the same reason and there are
countless other examples of this rule
that you can find in the real world and
I challenge you to name some of them in
the comment section below I'll pick up
my favorite one and send you a free real
engineering t-shirt this video was made
possible by hover the easiest and best
place to register a custom domain or
email they have over 400 domain
extensions and the best customer service
in the business seriously
they've won awards I couldn't believe my
luck when I saw that the real
engineering domain was available on
hover and purchased it immediately and
it took less than 20 seconds to make it
mine I now have a custom email address
that couldn't suit my channel better if
you are looking for a unique domain name
hover is the best place to get one and
you can get 10% off your next purchase
using the code real engineering you
could get the real dot surf domain to
use for your surfing videos or maybe you
want the real dot adult domain name and
pretend that you are one whatever domain
you want you'll probably be able to find
one that suits your needs at hover and
once again you can get 10% off your next
purchase using the code real engineering
there's been a slight delay for my next
video on ICBM defense and I've committed
to posting videos at least every second
Friday so please forgive how short this
video is thanks for watching and thank
you to my patreon supporters for helping
this channel exist
[Music]
[Music]